what was the grain of the idea how did
this concept come to be you kind of mash
up your adolescence you're looking well
yeah I don't like we're like obviously
moving big moving or have always been
that's what we wanted to do and we
started to get into television as it
became more and more cinematic yes
shorter seasons they started feel like
big movies and so we're like it was like
true detective Cary Fukunaga doing that
and Stephen sort of hurt the Knicks and
we just started going I'm Adam as a
kinder more excited by this stuff on
saying on television if you even want to
call it that and so it was like what
what would be the ultimate long movie
and it would be the over directing the
big fat Stephen King book and so John
Carpenter doing what yet John
Carpenter's with John Carr piano music
yeah right so that was that was that was
a dream and that was that that's that
was sort of ambition
we didn't think anyone was going to make
it so that was a nice surprise that's
the idea Wow right and then Sean how did
you get involved what made you go ah
well my executive Dan Cohen he comes to
me one day and he says you need to stop
what you're doing I've read this gripped
by these two twin brothers that no one's
ever heard of and it might be the best
thing I've ever read and I read it and
it was and I don't know kind of how it
was going to work and again we didn't
know if anyone's going to let us make it
and we definitely didn't know if
anyone's going to watch it um but I knew
that this combination of an eighties
backdrop genre and character
authenticity was going to be something
special and I told the brothers you know
what whatever you need that's what I'm
going to do and let's get this into the
world this was the fastest thing I have
revenged once I saw the font on the
title you were in write of it that's
every Stephen King novel bought that's
awesome how does that font have a name
you used to typically search that one
out or I don't well I do remember the
win we were coming up with the title
we're just testing out in the font we
wanted something to look good yeah it's
like in that red in that font it was it
was important to look good at I think it
got tweaked a little bit but even from
our lookbook on it was a version of that
we wanted to look at like one of those
Stephen King paperback that we do that
I'm sorry but I just know that Hall H
loves questions like that that's the
first thing I wanna know about also I
mean it's like that's it that's an
expression of the utter [ __ ] that the
brothers is like right now two font like
they did what they wanted from the font
before we even made the show and that's
how the good stuff you knew it important
and then um the the composer that the
soundtrack of this show is fantastic
have you heard about like visit because
I remember when when Twin Peaks came out
in the early 90s that Angelo Badalamenti
music began showing up and like I would
remember going to clubs and they would
play that music has the stranger things
being made it's waned and that's a
perfect end of rave yeah and to get
everyone to start going down because the
doctors are always at rate exactly I
think they are again we're still playing
before the band comes out and stuff like
that I'm really happy for these guys on
my call and they're you know they're
amazing they're at Austin they had never
composed for film or TV before really
baby what made you pick them then like
what date they had a since been called
survive and we were we were into them
and and we tested it over like footage
of you know EP and all the stuff that we
matched up together we thought it was
cool
and they did some you know test samples
and then we said you know they had day
jobs you can't make a living as an
electronic musician and ah wait a minute
they weren't making that easy skin
demand money no they were cut I don't
know here wait they were I did you know
will you quit your job do this
hell yeah and here we are I love the
commitment of the 80s you went for a
stint band because one of them play a
keytar because that would make it even
more perfect
there was a keytar in there somewhere
they've got I don't know what probably
everything every everything yeah one of
them workers uses an electronic source
of it well I used you in it the lower a
is there anything more often than a use
in the store yeah that a guy is sorry
unless you're selling pot out of the
back there's no okay well let's how
about we bring on the cast from season
one yeah
I'm sorry hang on no I'm being told ask
more synth questions okay so what was it
before finally well first out the of
course the girl next door with the tough
side
Nancy wheeler ladies and gentlemen
Natalia Dyer and then o we of course
have the Hawkins heartthrob please do
not rush the stage as Steve Harrington
Joe Keary
[Applause]
yes please welcome the best police chief
in Hawkins Indiana hey Harvard bringing
back good yeah tell boys Cowboys got a
dad bod okay
and now yeah already and now we have the
mad scientist tool stop it nothing dr.
Martin Brunner played of course by
Matthew Modine ladies and gentlemen is
Matthew Moody
without telling ecstasy all day now he's
here that's right sit down man - yeah
Wow you'd be more men you're gonna turn
into a skateboard like just sort of
unknown your self God there is not there
is not a kid in the world who can handle
a slingshot better than this guy please
welcome the ultimate Santana wearing
badass Lukas and Claire Hale if
mcLaughlin ladies and gentlemen
oh and next we have the kid with the
biggest heart the dopest hat and the
most beautiful smile
Dustin Henderson gave moderato and now
the only boy who is escaped the upside
down will Byers Noah snapped lead woman
[Applause]
next up the ringleader of the pack and
everyone's favorite best friend it's
Mike wheeler thin wolf hardly
development then wolf hard an actor born
with the greatest porn name ever
hey Nancy it really puts a great thing
on my future okay get a good agent we
just keep your lab but they go to things
okay it's just with the next deck huh
just don't do anything call stranger
song picante and lastly thank you
you still got it ah slow lastly in a
world of 10 B and 11 let's do them and
welcome to girl who can flip her mind
really Bobby Brown
[Applause]
all right um so Finn yeah Finn wolf hard
dude how did you when you nail it take
you look at the camera go whoop our one
single bar and they kicked me out how
did you get into the mind of Martin
Willy you really nail what it's like to
be when you're a kid and you're actually
a little more mature and intelligent
than the other kids and sometimes that's
not an advantage that you know like you
kind of how did you get into that
mindset in the show because I remember
moments like that growing up like oh
people don't want you to be this smart
so how like how did you nail that so
well uh I mean I'm not like that in real
life which is but I don't know I think
it's it's kind of cool because you can
sort of access your intensities and
bring out that sort of weird vibe I'm
not really sure I mean being smarter
than all the rest of the kids is I don't
think Mike the character realizes that
he's really smarter than us because I
think he's just like oblivious to
everything
Wow no cool yeah that was it
um and now Noah and I don't want I don't
want to make you do any spoilers but how
has your character changed from being in
the upside down coming back like what
without that's a weird question I don't
want to spoil the next season but I mean
how did you I'm going to let you try to
answer my horrible but yeah um I think
this compared to last season we'll
definitely shows more bravery um and
then you you'll definitely learn how the
upside down affected will and you'll get
more into a storyline but there's not
much I can say because I don't want to
spoil anything your producers glaring at
you right now I'm sorry I see that yeah
exactly
um Gaytan Caleb you guys are the
you I mean you guys are playing
characters that are faced with a lot of
weirdness and horror and you stay very
very optimistic and upbeat and you're
about to deal with a new character that
we're going to meet in a little bit
played by Sadie sink how do you think is
that going to change the dynamic of the
group or like what what do we what do we
have to look forward to from you guys as
characters these questions man the
producers are just like Sara Nana's feel
safe is a little bit no it's kind of
hard to like loop around yeah like just
talk about the story because I mean it's
a fun story ah you know look we are
friends like I said there was meat right
how's it going is it going well is it
going all right yes thanks Caleb did you
have to do slingshot training did you
today whoa okay I was like it all right
you know I realized that like I did it
wrong what like I held it weird in the
beginning and then I had to learn I like
the actually the actual day where I had
to like try to slingshot the demo Gorgon
I was kind of like shooting it at the
camera and everyone else around there so
I kind of had to teach myself and like
also like the duffer's were helping me
out like a good idea and so I guess yeah
yeah real training just was like more
than one person it's like you're gonna
die though huh
did you hit mark in the eye no no I mean
I thought you might say no you're just
said she was there you know I thought I
thought I remember you hitting the earth
ah what now Millie you have yes I mean
[Music]
you have minimal lines in this first
season and you have become this global
phenomenon so how do you play a
character that speaks so little but
expresses so much like how did you get
into that I mean it was difficult
because obviously I had I had very few
lines and I had to do everything you
know express everything with my face
which is very hard but it gets easier
when you feel more comfortable with your
character the first two episodes
actually I immediately fell in love with
11 and 11 was me so every day come on
set and I think the only thing I was
hard was crying because I'm such a I
feel like her I feel like I'm a happy
person so in real life so that when I'm
crying it doesn't come a cried like oh
five minutes to kind of get in the zone
but other than that I mean it was it was
difficult to portray such a hard
character but yeah like I said it gets
easier it's hard to keep a straight face
with you know teen boys because they
they play pranks and they tell a lot of
jokes like when I'm doing an emotional
scene she's talking about David by the
way yeah I mean it is unprofessional but
[Laughter]
but you know overall it was it was
alright David Cay Harbor what's up
comic-con
yeah oh man we're not selling timeshares
Dave Howard is heaven
I got a Glock on you get a free clock
radio if you just listen to my pitch
come on Pat and ask a question um well
okay you and I have kind of become
friends yeah we don't aim Twitter we
have a Twitter broke man
and so we hang out with each other
sometimes Oh all right hot enough not
enough okay go ahead cool all right just
want to establish that question for math
you know like again a lot of these
questions that I I don't like at what
they here's the question how is chief
hopper in season two but I don't want
you guys have to give stuff away the
last we saw of you you're leaving Eggos
or 11 you're now you've accepted you
went from this very cynical this is not
yes yes I don't know I will say
something kind of serious I mean like
one of the great things about season
want at least for a cheap hopper is that
he does get to go on such a classic
hero's journey right like he starts out
like such a jerk and such a loser so
horrible and you hate him and then know
it's true and don't worry I know how to
play that and then by around Episode
four you're like this guy is super
awesome and if he dies I'm suing Netflix
I feel the same way I mean oh right
come on keep those emails coming by the
way there's no one walking to the NSA
but um but I will say so the journey was
so satisfying to see him come to life
and I often say that like that breath
that he takes after he revives will
where I almost killed Noah Schnapp doing
CPR he sort of either wakes up right
yeah and so in season two it's like it's
a year later and you can't start where
you you can't do the same thing you
can't wake up again so I think one of
the really interesting subtle things
about the arc in season 2 which I can
tell you is that there is a psychology
of a heroic action where someone does
something heroic and then whether or not
they can live up to that in their daily
life or whether or not there are perils
even of your own being a savior complex
and the sort of intricate psychology of
like what that makes you as a human
being and the pitfalls of that so you're
going to see a wildly different arc in
season two but to me it's just as
satisfying like where we get to in the
end and it all begins with leaving Eggos
for a character in the woods who he
feels like might still be out there and
he's got some daughter issues of his own
as you're well aware so yeah so I'll
just leave it at that and then a
question that got texted to me will they
be more sheriff hopper shirtless scene
haha that was yeah yeah nobody needs it
that was the one the hate mail we got
from Netflix like please the the
marshmallow body on David Arbor enough
with that where it no no you know hey
whoa I got da ice you know we'll we'll
definitely offer gets to do some very uh
some very thrilling sexy things in
season zero so enjoy kids question for
Matthew uh yeah you have played some of
my favorite most difficult complicated
character movies like birdie and and yet
thank you and so Europe you also play a
very complicated ambiguous character in
this series we talked about how you got
into that into your character here oh
dear what's up San Diego anybody here
from San Diego that lived here whoa
get him out Uriel Beach local right here
Patton I I don't I don't have any way of
answering that question other than to I
mean the wonderful duffer brothers and
Shawn Levy they created an amazing
script that provided each of us with
with characters that's where it all
begins you know and you got you you you
take those words and you try to create a
character and bring that person to life
it was a it was a it was a great
pleasure in
yeah I can't be any more complicated
than that I went to acting school and
they taught me how to do it
Wow nice now
Natalia and Joe yes coach Wow tell us
with no spoiler all the questions
they're all spoilers I'm sorry but like
what do you think is going to be
happening with you guys what can you
tell us about where you guys are heading
in season two huh you know what
everybody how much talking did you do to
the duffer brothers about because
they're juggling really all these
characters they everyone on the show
does have arcs so how much input or how
much did you talk to these guys about
where the characters would be going and
how they would develop and change or I
feel like almost every time a new script
would come out we would kind of read the
script and all talk about at me
Charlie Natalia and especially kind of
all of our relationships together and
then kind of have a little conference
with the boys about you know what their
thoughts were what our thoughts were and
then kind of collaborate and come to
this agree right yeah but I also loved
how they you two are playing very
standard 80s film archetypes you know
like the the pretty girl and the bad boy
jerk boyfriend but then you're
definitely are you turn out heroic you
turn like it's they add all these
dimensions to you and they you think you
have a lot of fun going let's let's
start them as cliches and then open up
all these elements to them right that's
really interesting was that fun to play
or I mean yeah I saw I mean a credit to
uh to these boys for for you know giving
us characters that are more than what
they seem that are complex and I don't
feel very real and that's that's
honestly that's a gift and it's a lot
it's a lot of fun yeah it's like it's
like I'm on the paper it seems very
one-sided where I remember like reading
the first episode you read the character
and it could just be some jerk but I
think you know at the end of the day you
want to bring a real person you know to
this thing that is such a great group of
people so yeah I think it's just about
trying to like find the human moments
in the script and kind of you guys may
want it was really amazing and I
understand that there are some
additional cast members you would like
to introduce us to now um yeah I mean I
guess I don't know how I got to be in
charge of this but I'm going to do it
that's the rumors wrong the first person
I am going to introduce is a new
character named Billy and it's played by
Baker Montgomery and next we have Matt
aka Mad Max played by the wonderful lady
sink and we have to do with auditioning
cute Hawkins lab dr. Owen plays I Paul
Reiser
takers Montgomery tell us a little bit
about your character this new season
yeah um well just to start I was amazing
oh I was a huge fan of the first season
so this is amazing to kind of see this
up there and be part of it yeah I think
a little bit about my character is the
doctors were very vocal with me about
playing around with as you see here
monsters like as an antagonist and they
kind of wanted to play around with me as
a human antagonist so dropping a little
bit of spice into a recipe that you all
know and love is an honor and I hope
that I can be scary enough well I want
to give away too much else but um it's
been a lot of fun thank you Wow and now
a Paul Reiser we all rise a little
question I worked at Zanies in Chicago a
week after you back in 1989 I in a condo
I left a cassette tape it was
smithereens and did you so I guess I
have it I haven't no I thought you'd
answer it but I got it okay I needed
that back so you had um I'm in a series
if this event show will be any good if
you see it from a distance because for
like looking up like that it's
unbelievable oh I know it was very close
and very low it spent time know what
this next season the jumpers have asked
if you would lay on the floor under your
TV and watch it that way that was when
they show it again I'm going to try to
rally all that was can we all do that
yeah oh my god
now you look good from down there look
good all right
now am i assuming rightly the Euro
villain or not or what who you yes
you're assuming I am assuming that
you're assuming I won't say I I think
it's understandably they're a little
nervous about the guy who's coming into
a place this freaking guy who was no
good I always said it I said it by the
way in earlier films I said that guy's
no good but so I basically come in to
from the government to clean up
Brenner's mess and yeah not a mess we'll
see what not a mess but it was untidy
it was certainly on time and certain
things happen okay
why do you assume that I'm not like
there's these look your scenes are
sinister yes see you got wires on a
clear so ha ha ha don't even put it in
the trailer that's how brutal and and
and lively my stuff okay maybe too much
for these people you're a funny actor
but you're also good at playing citizen
I was not sad when you got eaten and
aliens I'm sorry you were a good mister
back
[Applause]
okay that was a little you know he's not
gonna set back now baby now Sadie you
are joining the kids you are playing a
character take Mad Max so how do you
interact with them what if you like best
about when did you watch the first
season yes I watched the first season
all my friends loved it mm-hmm no I
didn't loved it I loved it that's what
made getting the audition really
exciting for me just knowing the show
and I knew Caleb and Gaytan before oh
you did yeah we're all on Broadway
together
you're on Broadway to get that oh my god
yeah thank you
i wolfhard I knew something hard meet me
in the parking lot three whoa so not not
the face though this is how I make my
money again without spoilers like how do
you how do you join the group or Church
we just wait to find this out I feel
weird asking this but mmm
how do I join the group Oh
I mean she's from California so that's
how she fits into season two okay let's
leave it at that I don't write yeah well
anything so now I'm we I wanted to us
see if we have any questions from the
audience I wanted to open up the panel
now spotlight look at the spotlight
[Applause]
wandering bark season - Shannon purser
[Applause]
I'm up here oh my god
dad what was your question there's a
question ah I think he wasn't she was
going to be in season two I was
wondering if barb is going to be in
season two yeah I can answer that no oh
but there will be justice for barb
justice yeah arm bars will be avenged
you